[Musique]
alors ça y est paris réussis complet à
20h34 radio canada prévoit que le
prochain gouvernement de la caq sera
majoritaire dès demain on va se
retrousser les manches dès le moment où
un gouvernement car il ya des contacts
s'établissent pour fixer les premiers
invités de la noce de la victoire de la
coalition avenir québec une puissante
machine s'est mise en branle au sommet
de l'état pour assurer un transfert
harmonieux des pouvoirs jusqu'à
maintenant que ce quillard ce soir ils
ont été impeccables
ils ont offert leur leur disponibilité
pour faciliter la tension dont le québec
il faut se le dire les tensions se passe
bien
les décisions prises dans les tout
prochains jours sont cruciales pour bien
lancer le virage pro ni espoir de
changement sont immenses je tiens -
délai dans lequel est juste et ce budget
relatif humilité à la vérité
janvier payer développer les connaissant
déjà les aînés sont oubliées tu ne
penses et d'agde pour les aînés à
domicile
[Applaudissements]
martin tremblay a été chef de cabinet de
rené lévesque et sous ministre aux
affaires culturelles et internationales
c'est elle qui a supervisé la transition
dans pauline marois a pris le pouvoir en
le danger à éviter c'est que les gens
parlent trop vite c'est toujours pareil
il faut qu'il ya une très très très
grande discipline le principal défi
c'est que c'est de démontrer que le
premier ministre sait où il vaut qu'il
est préparé qu'il a une très bonne idée
de ce qui va faire de son de ses cent
jours françois legault marche sur des
oeufs avec une fonction publique qu'il a
promis de dégraisser son défi délicat
changer la façon de gouverner sans
déstabiliser l'état toutes les manières
le risque existe toujours et encore une
fois il ya certainement une sorte
d'inconfort actuellement parce qu'on
sait pas ce qui va se passer
le seul moyen d'apaiser je te dise
toujours le mot apaisée c'est de dire
bah écoute et on en a besoin on a besoin
de vous pour réaliser nos engagements
confirme les voiles est un fonctionnaire
de carrière dirigera l'administration
publique
françois legault semble écouter les
anciens mandarin qu'il consulte on a une
fonction publique qui est compétent donc
je veux qu'on travaille ensemble
j'ai déjà des boîtes qui sont prêtes
aussi donc même au niveau très
logistique
on est prêts on est prêt à gouverner
jusqu'à l'assermentation des nouveaux
ministres
ce sont les libéraux qui détiennent le
pouvoir si une crise éclate d'ici là qui
la gère qui décideraient par exemple de
déployer la sûreté du québec m'ont déjà
contacter très étroit notre comité de
transition avec l'activé l'autre
fonction publique donc c'est certain que
quoi qu'il advienne que ce soit une
catastrophe ou autre on est toujours
consulter de très près l'arrogance il
faut savoir que la confiance des
québécois se mérite à tous les jours
j'ai l'impression qu'on n'est dès lors
plus devant une feuille blanche juste à
nous de les écrire convenablement
d'écrire l'histoire comme meneur
convenablement
e baird pas ce soir les nouveaux
dirigeants du québec se donne deux à
trois semaines pour former le conseil
des ministres ce sera le premier vrai
test de la volonté de changement du
premier ministre désigné ici sophie
langlois radio canada québec